knowing you and john and knowing some
people in the acting business who have
actually worked with their husbands
before
right when the husband writes and
directs a movie
and then his wife is going to be in it
it's all great
if the movie comes out in tanks they
nine times out of ten get a divorce
divorce yeah yes no but but seriously
emily like you ruined my career i did
this for you
and now it's over you're laughing about
it but
you know you know how many couples that
has happened luckily it hasn't happened
but like no but i know what you mean and
even in
whether the movie attacked or not when
we decided to work together there were a
lot of people
like you're going to be divorced by the
end of the movie like people were really
i said it like
i said crazy did you yes i said to my
wife we went out to dinner
maybe yeah you went out to dinner with
you and your husband and i heard the
plans that he had written a movie
and i'm saying i turned to my wife
afterwards i said they're so lovely but
they are so done
they're so done she's doing the movie
she shouldn't be doing this movie but
meanwhile who knew
john could direct him right the way he
died listen i didn't know
okay so then what convinced you his
script
i read it on a plane read it on a plane
and he i turned around and i really had
a cry because it was astonishing
and i said is there any way you would
want me to do this movie with you and he
was really
thrilled or he of course being very
thrilled
and the other thing that was the big
discovery is what a visual
hurricane he was just brilliant
to the point yes what are you doing with
the camera
i i would have no idea how to shoot that
movie
i was like he pitched me the idea and i
listened i've always known
he is supremely talented and actually to
speak very plainly with you
i was just waiting for the rest of the
world to sort of find out that he
was more than jim from the office and
for a long time
i know he wanted to that's a hard tail
to shake
like when you're beloved as jim halpert
and people are like that's what you are
and it is a business of
compartmentalizing people it is a
business of pigeonholing
yeah because i didn't think john
deserved you honestly i'll be honest
i thought maybe someone like myself did
i i really
would and and and john proved himself
when he wrote this movie and directed it
and now you were like oh he finally
deserves her yeah i get it now